i'm going to start with the most
important question first um
who is a better chess player you or guy
oh it depends really
depends on who's willing to lie
uh you know
in the early days
we were pretty neck and neck and i used
to take him uh
more times than he took me and he never
used to like it
clearly we're very competitive but you
know over the years he's
he's had a few lessons and he's had a
few more lessons and the lessons
have gotten in the way of me beating him
so occasionally we're about
you know i think every couple of games
well every 10 games say
he wins about
six or seven of those uh
you know he's
maybe six out of ten versus previous
games it'd be the other the other way
around so
he's slightly better than me and i don't
ever
don't ever tell him that i told you that
he told me when i asked him this uh
earlier he said that the only time you
win is when you cheat
you know he's a liar he's an out
and out liar he doesn't like it when i
win because he's had so many lessons and
so many you know private lessons
over the course of about 10 years that
it would really put him at a loss if he
does lose and and he occasionally does
if someone has actually never seen a
movie that you've done what is the first
one you want them watching and why
oh um
you know i'm very fond of those old guy
richie movies that i did so i'd say
maybe snatch
uh maybe lock stock
it would be a flip of the coin on those
two i think uh just because i think they
were just so
they were so
instrumental in my career um you know
i've done more
you know more i've done movies that are
more focused on me as a scent
centerpiece
but i think those early guy ritchie
movies are just
they're of i don't i don't know anyone
that couldn't enjoy them
really
i i completely agree uh jumping into
operation fortune i watched it last
night i just want to thank you because i
needed a movie like that just something
fun
you know i just had a lot of fun
watching and i have to know what was
your reaction when you saw hugh grant
and what he was doing with his accent
and character
first time you saw him on set uh because
he you know he's so fantastic in the
role in this
he's uh
he's tremendous in this movie yeah i
mean you know he he did a magnificent
job in the gentleman which i was a again
i was blown away by you know it's
another movie i wish i was in
can't be in all of them uh
but hugh is just he's so versatile you
know he's uh he's a terrific
he's got such a great depth to his
ability and i think to see him in a role
like this you know people have seen him
in
the you know he did decades of rom-coms
and to see him do something like this
it's so complex and so quirky and
i just think he's
he's just he's just been undersold i
think
this is just really something a special
skill that people need to see he's just
going great
i i completely agree um one of the
things that i find so fascinating about
guy and the way he directs is that uh
you might have a script going in but
each day he will completely rework
everything and you know come up with new
things new dialogue can you sort of talk
about what it's actually like working
with guy on a daily basis when he's so
spontaneous yeah i mean it it's uh it's
very unusual because normally you have a
semi-decent script that you're sort of
going to work with and you kind of know
that you've got a scene that's going to
work for you and you know you know you
know you know how to navigate that that
day's work
but you know
the script wasn't in great shape uh and
i think this is a position
that
in most
most situations where you'd be panicking
like what the hell is going to happen
today but i think guy likes to put
himself under pressure he likes to throw
the script out of the window he likes to
figure out
how he can make something out of nothing
and i think that that imminent pressure
that he puts on him
that he puts on himself
brings out the best of him it's a weird
very unusual thing but the more
difficult of a
day that's in front of him the better he
is as a director he's just
it's
the more pressure the more
flourishing is his dialogue it just
comes from nowhere
and you know you'll spend
half an hour in the trailer and he'll be
hashing it together
and at the end of the day it looks like
he's you know he's spent weeks and weeks
constructing these great scenes because
they're full of this original dialogue
it's uh it's an amazing thing to see so
the idea is don't get attached to
anything
don't learn your lines
try not to be attached to any of the
scenes that you think you might be
shooting
and just turn up and it's like a
workshop almost it's a very tricky thing
i don't think hugh was a particular fan
of it
because he had you know for him it was
much more difficult because he had a
much more in-depth
pieces of monologues you know
he had a lot more to say and i think to
kind of
go away and learn these big speeches
and then to come in and
go going and i've just learned i spent
three days learning that speech
what do you mean you've changed all my
lines so for someone for a character
like hugh
that he was playing i think it'd be much
more frustrating because you would have
put time and efforts into them so a
little easier for myself because he was
a less sort of vocal sort of character
but nevertheless it's still uh
it's still the process that guy likes
and same with the action turn up work it
out on the day no rehearsals no stunt
training no stuntmen this is what we're
doing
this is how we do it it's literally like
student filmmaking
but in a most professional way of course
one of the things about aubry is that
she is so funny and i would imagine
working with her because she's you know
she's so good at improvisation uh how
many times did she actually get you to
break on camera
uh many she is so funny i mean she's
again she's got incredible
improvisational skills and a lot of the
funny lines that she delivers actually
came from her you know she's so good
and she's
unconventional to the
to a point that you could never put your
finger on how
how quirky and how funny she is her
timing is so great and she's just so
watchable she's my new favorite actress
i love aubrey plaza
well it's interesting i spoke to guy and
i asked him um what do i need to do to
get you and jason to make 10 more movies
and he said that uh uh that's going to
happen don't worry and then he was
giving you about his next movie in
spain and uh how he you're not gonna be
in it but you know
anyway but it made it seem like i'm so
happy that you guys are back working
together have you both talked about
other projects that you want to do uh
yeah we have but you know
we're trying to figure it out i mean we
don't want to just you know i think it's
great that he's going to do a movie i'm
going to go do uh a sequel to the meg
you know we're just about to start
shooting that and i think it might be
nice to have a little break he'll shoot
one i'll shoot one
we'll come back and figure something out
we we just
we enjoy the process we love what we do
and we love it more when we're doing it
together
um you have done such awesome action set
pieces uh i really just love watching
you kick ass um and i'm just curious
when you think back on the ones that
you've done which was the one or two
that you're like oh this is this is
pretty dangerous this is pretty hard
there have been a couple of situations
you know we was i think when we was when
i shot crank
we were hanging out of the
the real we was on a helicopter you know
a lot of the things you do now with
expendables and anytime you're on a
helicopter it's usually on a green
screen uh but with crank we were we were
actually in a helicopter we were
shooting a fight scene where was
standing on the skids we have a small
pic there so it was a real stunt you
know that one was pretty tricky there
was some
there was a couple of sort of jumps in
that movie over this car park i was
hanging on a gold tail it's quite
almost like a blind jump and
you know there was a few gig few things
in that gig that were pretty tricky i i
i did a little jump in the transport a
transporter two where i jumped from the
back of a jet ski onto
the back of a bus that wasn't
it wasn't a very safe stunt i shouldn't
have done it there was no safety wire
but i just did that i mean if i'd have
if i'd have missed the back of the bus
it would have been a you know face plant
at 30 miles an hour into the concrete
there's silly things that i've done most
of the most annoying things you know
like
i've had a torn bicep
you know you have to try and finish the
movie most of the things are just real
niggles and problems with your soft
tissue and your joints
uh you know i've hurt my neck
i've got so many injuries that have
accumulated over the past just doing
stunts and hitting the ground and
you know
in the mechanic
the sequel to the mechanic i really
screwed up my neck doing this jump into
a into a
from one high platform on the back of
the boat into this you know dinghy
taking a couple of shots i've done i've
done a lot of silly stunts that i didn't
need to do that i could have just relied
on a double to do and i think my
my physical self would have been in much
i would be in a much better position
i've just got
they've taken their toll you know i'm
nursing a lot of bad injuries stallone
in himself he he's he's got
a road map of injuries over the course
of his career and you know a lot of the
things we do it's
because our ego gets in front of us and
we wanna we wanna we want it to be
authentic we want people to see that
that's us doing it we want the uh the
audience to go for the ride
uh and a lot of the decisions i think
i'm getting a bit smarter now i think
i'll you know i'll try and uh i'll try
and be smarter because of the necessity
to be smarter as my body's wearing out a
little bit
some of the little heck niggles anyway
i completely understand um i seriously
just want to thank you for your work
you've i've really enjoyed watching you
work i'm out of time i just want to say
congrats on the movie i wish you nothing
but the best thanks steve always a
pleasure talking to you respect see ya
you